So now we get the code Works Crusader on our
screen
And the position that we want them to be in
awesome so now we just need to go back to
our HTML and actually add in his name
beneath
So now we actually need to go back to our
HTML and add his name beneath
So from here let's actually go underneath
this image check and we'll add in our own P
tag and we're just going to say the code
Works Crusader here
We're not doing anything too fancy here we
just want to make the font sizeEssentially
an H1 and we also want to add in this light
text.
So let's go to our Styles at CSS and create
that class
Sooner Styles at CSS let's just go ahead and
create light textYou scroll down here.
And this is going to be obviouslyA light
color. But we're going to want to make sure
we add in that text shadow.
When I use the zero pixel zero pixel 5 pixel
and we're going to make it black
After this we're going to add in our text
decorationYou can get dotted.
- double line through underlineAnd that's
which one we're going to choose here we're
going to get that underline.
So save that and head to our applicationNow
we get the.
World renowned coder the code Works Crusader
over here
And at this point I'm going to come back to
the buttons but I kind of want to work on
the boss now just to get that visually
appealing battle going on
And I can always recommend Also let's go
ahead and test this outSo our health is
still going down properly awesome.
Sweet so let's go actuallyLet's go get our
villain over there on the right.
So let's head down to our villainAnd we'll
start the same way we did the other one so
let's just use text Center.
And then we'll say Crusader height here as
well
But now reading the state high on the
villain I kind of want to change the name
So let's actually change this Crusader
heightWe'll change this to height.
75 I don't thinkSo we'll change this to
height 75.
And let's just actually go up here and
change this to height 75 as well
Just to add more reusability because
technically at that point
Is it fine to continue using a class name
that isn't implied for that section 100%
that's okay but
I just want to keep some reusability dude I
should have originally started with like
something height 75 but
From here we can go down to our next row
And this is going to look very similar to
our hero we'll just do just by content
Center for that as wellWill change this
column here to a call 10.
And from here we will change us from the
villains height to the coding virusesHealth.
And from here we'll add that font size to
this as wellLet's make this a font size 3.
And.
Three and we'll also add in that custom
header text on it as well
And I am going to spice it up here
And change this to 250 we're going to make
him a little bit stronger I feel like the
game was a little too easy
So if we change it to 250 here cuz this is
going to be the starting point we need to
make sure we go to our JavaScript
Unless actually set the villains healthTo
250 here.
And will probably have some problemsLater on
as well and I can show you how we can clean
that up to make this more reusable as well.
But we'll do that after we get this image on
here so we'll go to this row like I said
make sure we'll
go outside this room and we'll do the same
thing with this we'll create an image with
the source of our assets
And we'll get the coding virus in hereAnd
we'll do an all tag of.
Coding virus bossWill add a title of. The
coding virus.
And I'll also add an ID here for coding
virus as well if we want to like say do any
cool stuff later on we'll
cuz I plan on adding some extra CSS here at
the end once we kind of get this running the
way we want it to
And lastly for this guy will add that final
P tag with just his name so we'll say the
coding virus
And will give it a font size of one and
we'll give it that light text as well so
let's go take a look at this
That's a big dude
So now I got the coding Mega virus
apparently
Over here just he actually looks kind of
cool but I'm getting some side school here
so it's just way off the screenDoing his own
thing.
And that's because I forgot to put that
height 75 on them and
he's just going to his native height and
he's going to he's massive
So from here I forgot to add that class like
we had on our hero and that's going to be
that height 75
All right now that looks like a little bit
more achievable
So now we have our code representer on the
left and our coding virus on the right and
you'll notice though when I attack
Everything is working the way I wanted to
And you can see these alerts in like said be
a little obnoxious sometimes but we get
Leave I wanted to skip all the clickingYeah
we'll just.
At this point we got our coding virus on the
right or hero on the leftAll we have left is
to get these buttons looking the way we
want.
All we need to do all that's left is to get
these buttons to look the wayHow do I mess
this up twice.
All that's left to do is get these buns to
look the same way as they did in that
reference project
So let's now go to our buttonWe can already
have our own click on here and for both of
them in the type button which is awesome.
So from here we'll actually take off this
BTN outline dark and we'll just leave the
BTN on both of them
And from here I'm going to add an image tag
And the source of that image is going to be
once again in our assets and where I'm going
to get the attack PNG
And my ALT will beAttacked.
And I'm going to sign a title to this as
well and this is going to be the attack
button
It should figure it out based off this P tag
kind of being the identifier for this button
but
Worst case scenario you just spent a second
putting this title in but
make sure we always have these all tags in
once again for accessibility
And on this image I want to add a classAnd
I'm going to use that image food class.
I'm going to add in a custom CSS class of
attack Button as well
So down on the drink potion we're going to
do the same exact thing we're going to
Target that assets and we're going to Target
my
Magic transparent potion
And then we'll have our drink potion and
then I'll add in the same title for drink
potion button
And I'll add some and I'll add in some
custom CSS classes for this as well
And I'm going to reuse that attack button so
let's just go ahead and change this from a
tag button now
Let me ask you to look what my buns doing
And we'll just we'll actually tap into our
same styling as
bootstrap so I'll use BTN and then I'll just
say BTN
Custom let's just say custom for now
something simple
Since we're going to use on both of these so
let's go ahead and go to our CSS and
actually style this button custom
So I'll make a new section for this and I'll
say buttons
And let's do our BTN custom here
And what we want our fun custom to do is
we're going to set this to a custom width of
95%And we're going to make this have a.
75% opacity
And when I go to hover on this B10
I wanted to then increase its opacity to one
so we want to make it completely visible
And I'm going to set the width to 100 so
this is going to give it an effect of making
it grow and become
More obvious as wellSo save everything and
let's head to our web application.
So just like that we now have our our
buttons here
So when I hover over this attack like I said
it starts kind of a little bit barely opaque
and when I actually highlight over it
makes it fully opaque and it kind of gives
it that slight grow as well just because I'm
increasing the width from 95 to 100
And the same effect works on this potion
down here as well
So very cool at this pointYou can call it
good and you could actually just finish this
project but from.
here we're going to add some other cool
things we can do with our JavaScriptLike I
mentioned earlier I added those.
I added those IDs to the image tags
And at this point I want to make it so when
my heroes Health hits zero
I want to add some sort of feature that
Makes them grayed out or I can even change
this to possibly like a giant tombstoneAnd I
can do the same with the virus as well.
I don't like that though
So from here we can actually let's close up
some of this stuff here
We're going to go into our draw Health
function
And from here we can even take this a step
furtherAnd we can divvy out this so we can
actually say do this as draw hero.
And we can make another function for Dylan
as well
We'll actually stabilize draw hero health
and draw villain health
And let's actually just go ahead and cut
this up here
And then we'll do the same here
And then for our draw Health at this point
we can just call those in here